foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ago and take a look at some Mida hole
quandaries that have been sent our way
and it's been a few weeks since we've
had a chance to answer these so we'll
start with cat who says hi Matt I've
listened to you for a long time I
appreciate your ability to articulate
sound judgment I began to follow you
when I read the article you wrote after
Bruce Jenner came out as Caitlyn
absolutely perfect I was hoping to get
your take on a situation that's still a
little contentious in my marriage my
husband's an avid fantasy football
player he typically wins a decent amount
of money while doing so we've only been
married a short while so in the past
he's always kept his winnings for
himself however we have a son together
plus he has a daughter from a previous
relationship and we have some debt this
year when he won his fantasy football
money since I managed the finances I
asked him to put the money in savings or
put it towards some of the debt he said
it was his money that he won it and that
it was extra he and I have a different
definition of extra extra to me would be
cash that isn't needed elsewhere since
we do need it elsewhere it is an extra
he spent most of the money on a VR
Gaming System we got into a huge fight
because I was upset that he bought it I
accused him of being selfish and only
thinking of himself shouldn't have been
so harsh with my words but at the same
time I believe as a man as a leader of
our home he should be concerned about
finances and want to give to his family
before himself he accused me of only
caring about money which is not true but
I do manage the finances I don't like
managing the finances but truthfully he
can't be trusted uh he came from a poor
town in New Mexico his father died when
he was very young so from his
perspective he says he struggled his
whole life he knows what it's like and
he will manage but those don't seem like
words of wisdom to me if he knows what
it is like to struggle then he should do
everything in his power to avoid said
struggle for his kids so who uh who's
the who's the a-hole is it what you're
asking well the good news is that you uh
you probably won't be surprised to learn
this you are not the first married
couple to have a dispute about something
like this about money money right this
is one of those things where I am only
getting one side of the story I'm
guessing if I were to talk to him he
would probably fill me in on some
details that you've left out and not
because you're trying to be dishonest
but because you you you know we're all
biased in our own favor naturally but
based on what you've told me I would say
say you're not the a-hole and I would
give two reasons one is that in a
functioning marriage and a healthy
marriage there's no such thing as well
this is my money this is just money
money has to be shared it just has to be
in a marriage that's how you have to see
it and once you start playing this game
of this is all mine you're headed to a
dark place and it's like nothing good
can come of it you have to have the
attitude of this is our money it's for
the family family family
which doesn't mean that as a member of a
marriage you can't spend some money
quote on yourself and buy some things
that you want to buy for yourself but it
should all go to the same place the same
bank accounts that you all have access
to uh nobody's hiding money no one's
keeping it off in some you know locked
away so the other person can't can't
access it I think once you start going
down that path it's just not nothing
good comes of it and I also think you're
right about the the VR thing too I I
just like people know that I'm not I'm
not a video game fan myself I don't play
them but with the VR thing that goes
another to another level right because
now you're talking about those like a
headset that so now now you you know you
you you're completely removing yourself
from your physical environment
what's what's the moderate amount what's
the correct amount of putting on a VR
headset as an adult and a father in your
home maybe there's a you can practice
moderation with something like that too
but you'd have to really really limit
your time and already the financial
investment you're spending hundreds of
dollars when you've got these other
Financial Obligations you have to meet
that already tells you that this is not
a moderate thing so I'm gonna be on your
side on this one got you covered people
are raving about genucel products
somebody named Claire said I absolutely
love genocell my skin feels so good
Tighter and younger with a more even
tone and I've only been using it for a
week nothing works like genucel it's a
family recipe that's been perfected over
20 years by compounding pharmacists who
works in small batches and with only
safe natural cruelty free ingredients
here are some of them I have to show you
this is what they look like with warmer
weather just around the corner and our
friends at Jenny cell are including two
Springtime Essentials in their most
popular package the ultra retinol and
dark spot director Ultra retinol
contains a powerful retinal alternative
that is safe for your skin the Dark Spot
Corrector will help reduce sun spots
plus you'll still get genu cells
world-class under eye bag therapy to
help alleviate puffiness you'll see
results in 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back try genucel's most popular
package for 70 off at genucel.com Walsh
YT all orders are upgraded to free
shipping in every subscription order
includes a complimentary spring spa box
with free spa Essentials so go to
genucel.com Walsh YT genucel.com
Anonymous says am I the a-hole for
sometimes blocking the sidewalk in my
neighborhood there are full adults
living in my home at the moment full
adults as opposed to half adults
myself and my husband my brother and my
sister-in-law my brother and
sister-in-law are both in college and
work jobs my husband and I also have
full-time jobs thus we have four cars
that are necessary for all of us to
function in society the HOA has a rule
that if you park on the street you'll
get ticketed or towed we've received
multiple tickets from doing this so
instead at night when we're all home one
of us parks in the garage and three
parks in the driveway which causes one
of the cars to block the sidewalk now
there's a state regulation that asks no
one to block sidewalks for any reason I
believe it's the Disability Act however
it's not enforced and there's no one in
my area of the neighborhood who's in a
wheelchair or anything like that however
my neighbors are extremely annoyed that
we block the sidewalk at night we first
began with them sending pictures to HOA
and those photos being sent to my
landlord by the HOA then they left a
note on my windshield saying that it's
absurd that we block the sidewalk and
that the whole street asks us stop
yesterday they tagged my husband and I
in a Facebook post that reminds people
of the neighborhood not to block the
sidewalk with a caption that says please
read this I was shocked by this because
I've never even met these people so I
have no idea how they know our names
after we didn't respond one of them
waited for my sister-in-law to come home
so they could yell at her to stop
parking on the streets she says that a
child almost got hit by a car recently
and that old people have to walk around
our cars are we the holes for blocking
our sidewalk when we truly are not given
any other option no no and look you're
doing it at night right so you're
putting you're putting uh you're parking
the cars like that at night you don't
have any other option what else are you
supposed to do it's it's not actually
affecting anybody else and so these are
our neighbors that are looking for a
problem and getting annoyed by something
that doesn't affect them in the
slightest you need to come
you said that your your neighbors don't
know your name in all admit I've been
guilty of this but it used to be that
you know it used to be kind of like
Unthinkable that you would live in a
neighborhood and you wouldn't even know
the names of the people who live around
you but now it's pretty common like
you'll live in a neighbor you live there
for years and not even know anyone
around you you never talk to them and so
that's bad enough the only time they
take an interest in you is to complain
about how you park your car now there
they holes for sure finally from Aaliyah
says I'm the newest roommate in a
college house with three other girls and
being in college I know that people are
going to drink on the weekends but one
of my roommates came home one night so
drunk that she relieved herself on the
kitchen floor
I reached out to my landlord and tried
getting her kicked out because she
refused to clean it
okay and I was forced to clean it the
next morning in my day hope for trying
to get this girl who has been at the
house the longest evicted since I'm the
newest tenant at this house
um no are you are you even considering
the possibility that you might be in the
wrong on this one so you are on your
hands and knees on the kitchen floor
cleaning up someone else's urine I'm
assuming it was urine and you want the
person who peed on the floor like a dog
kicked that out and you're thinking to
yourself you might be in the wrong no
you're 100 in the right the part that
blows my mind I mean the whole thing
we're leaving yourself on the kitchen
floor is already disgusting but she
refused to clean it
how did that conversation work hello
you're so drunk
I assume you you went up to her right in
some kind of conversation where you said
can you urinated all over the kitchen
floor can you clean it please and she
said no
I wouldn't want to live with this person
for sanitation reasons but also just
because this is someone who's mentally
unstable I don't find this funny anymore
it never was supposed to be and uh given
the reaction the next like she's sober's
up the next day and refuses to clean it
that blows my mind so no you are uh
relieved of that moral burden I guess
everybody was during this segment it's
always fun we could do that and we'll
leave it there for today God Speak
there's something wrong with your toilet